bonjour je m'appelle je pars de vie donc
j'ai 20 ans
moi je suis spécialisé dans la
décoration de salle avec ballon c'est un
concept encore peu connu ici à la
Réunion donc c'est l'argument qui nous a
poussé à ouvrir nous ce qu'on a apporté
donc dans ce domaine c'est notre produit
phare qu'on a lancé en 2014 à savoir le
centre de table avec ballon la première
année était un peu difficile parce que
la plume n'est pas essentiellement
accessible donc on a trouvé des
alternatives on sollicitant des artistes
pour la publication de votre page
facebook
pour que ça touche un maximum de
personnes et c'est vraiment sur ces
réseaux sociaux qu'on récolte la
majorité de nos contrats on s'adresse à
tous les acteurs économiques donc les
ménages les futurs mariés les comités
d'entreprise donc tout ce qu'il y a qui
fait référence à la fête donc pour les
gens qui aiment une décoration originale
autre que les décorations de table donc
on vient en complément justement de
cette déco et l'on travaille en
partenariat avec des décoratrices quand
on regarde tous ces jeunes qui triment
pour chercher un boulot ou tous ces
patrons qui font la sorte d'oreille donc
c'est ce qui nous pousse à ouvrir notre
propre entreprise on sait les
difficultés on est jeune peut-être mais
on a vraiment une maturité qui qui nous
est propre et qui nous pousse justement
à saisir ses responsabilités et agrandir
face à ces responsabilités